he'll be appearing at the Addison improv
this weekend in Addison Texas next
weekend at the Houston improv and the
week after at side splitters in Tampa
Florida
he is from countless movies
he's sports shows you know he's he's my
brother in a lot of struggles and uh and
he was our first guest and I'm happy to
have him back here ladies and gentlemen
my friend mr. J Moore
[Music]
you will be doing fine
you will always be doing fine yeah you
will always like when I just came in you
were like I said it's a jungle there and
you're like there's some just it's just
dirty dogs yeah I'm like but we're
always gonna win because we're the
champion dogs yeah I was talking about
like I didn't tell you there's dirty
dogs out there but we're always gonna
beat them yeah because we're game yeah
dog fights are always I told you it's
gonna tell you this dog the perception
of dog fights in the United States is so
misconstrued because of Michael Vick
like shooting a dog and electrocuting
and thrown in the pool put it in a
[ __ ] headlock and put it all of that
really oh yeah I didn't read all of that
yeah I read the first just defuse the
dogs and people the united states that
have dog fights they're not good to the
dogs but if you go to places where it's
legal like the Philippines or Brazil oh
yeah the champions the dog feeds a town
he's Muhammad Ali yeah so you can't
mistreat it like the dog is to cut
weight right it's got a fee eat the most
spectacular food it sleeps with its
handler if two pit bulls are fighting
and you go to break him up if you're not
it's gonna bite your hand unless yeah it
knows you and loves you so much it would
never bite your hand so you can't
mistreat the dog it would bite you right
yeah so people think they fight to the
death they don't what happens in a dog
fight this is from Sam Sheridan's book a
fighter's heart they let the dogs go
they fight for a few seconds they pull
them apart they make the bets they let
the dogs go they fight for a few seconds
they pull them apart they bet this goes
on for three hours it's like a mating
dance almost keeps going yeah going like
five hours six hours until one dog
doesn't come out the other dog keeps
coming out because he's game that's the
dog who wins the dog fight the one that
just keeps coming right you lose a dog
fight by going ready to go like as soon
as that dog pauses it's over so finally
one dog just like I'm chillin I'm done
I'm not so sure like he kind of and the
owners are like go go go go but it's
over so like it's called gameness Wow a
dog that's game is always gonna win
sometimes they'll die cuz they're
two-game they don't know they're losing
they just keep coming they just keep
coming
they just keep coming in a good
handler will take his dog out because he
knows the dog will never stop but you
and I were game yeah
we have gameness that's all we know is
you just keep coming out it's gonna be
fine that's true ma'am you're gonna win
yeah I'm one with shoulders first a lot
of times I'm just going forward right
you know that's like y'all just keep
going right back into the fire people
are like do you have Vaseline all over
you do we're just in there now like I
gotta go back in there it's an illegal
substance game
yeah I think I left something in there
dude and uh yeah I can't believe that's
a beautiful to thinking Philippine you
go there and they got a dog probably
sleeping on like a you know they sleep
with the owner Oh sleep with the handler
that's [ __ ] unfortunate that's sad but
I know why is that said I mean I just
think it's that dogs the whole cash cow
for a town yeah I guess you probably
want to keep it with you all night then
look when that they have to they they
make sure no one messes with it they
feed it like Kobe beef and a lien from
that yeah that's crazy dog food yeah
director prizefighters their actual
prize fire yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't
[ __ ] just feed all evander holyfield
uh graham crackers you know it's a yeah
I got just some saltines real deal and
you want some potato salad and saltines
man saltines Britz crap would you say
what is a graham cracker I drag the
topping no it salty this is fun to watch
though because he has kind of darker
complexion I'm seeing a Saltine going to
his mouth is more of a he's so thirsty
yeah it's more of yeah be more of a
unique look what's going on man good to
see you bro how's the wrestling going
how's coaching going it's my favorite
thing in my life
you look jacked Kanha I'm doing good I
wrestle every day do you I'm not gonna
tell you to do something I'm not doing
yeah cuz when I the way we were coached
doesn't work yeah like really yeah oh
yeah Oh in high school 84 to 88 and then
college for briefly 89 actually 88 still
where'd you find indoors or outdoors
mostly was in the gym it's like you know
you just roll the wrestling mats out in
the gym and the wrestling room at
rockers oh yeah and it's like coaches go
my way or the highway you say that now
it's gonna be a real packed Highway
those kids who go really
you know they got their phones they got
their apps there I mean they're getting
laid Wow like we didn't have any life
when we were in high school I didn't oh
I know especially wrestling those kids
were just beaten the acne off of each
other it looked like and it's year-round
now too so it's like you're with these
kids for four years 12 months of the
year 3 2 hours a day 3 hours a day then
you seem on weekends and a tournament
takes like 10 hours all day they'll get
sick EU really quick if you're like my
way or the highway
I because I just coach the way I wish I
was coached oh wow I just tried to
communicate with him tell him I love
that's cool man
but yeah I'm not gonna go like do this
draw they've had front headlock and I'd
rather just show them can they do what
are some of the new moves people are
doing out there like what's kind of like
the new is there some no there's no like
new moves it gets a little like we call
it funk and once while there's some funk
like this new like thing where you do a
weird and it's just it all circles back
to the it's you know single leg double
leg front headlock spin behind get you
two points half-nelson one-on-one armbar
it's all you know cradle cradle cradle
it's all the same [ __ ] that's crazy and
a lot of strategy huh it's kind of like
high speed chess yeah and like the
sooner you can get thinking out of their
heads the better they'll be like you
want to sense like if I'm on bottom and
the guys on top I can sense he's too
high and I can roll him but I'm not like
okay if he gets too hot right you can't
you death my thought he can't be out
there with like a um a yardstick I got
where the guy's if he gets too high on
his ride I shall roll him now is it
homoerotic out there for do you see a
lot of you is it like a lot of give any
transgender wrestlers or anything like
that with you know your girls in the
room now that's very popular I love it
is it yeah I love it because they're
never gonna get assaulted in college oh
yeah that's true like you you got a 14
15 year-old girl on the wrestling room
and you realize every day you're keeping
her like you're teaching her and keeping
her from being sexually assaulted yeah
some guy in college gonna be drunk and
try to put her on a mattress and she's
just gonna be like later but they put
the rear choke and innate yeah you're
making jokes all right he could be fully
naked and [ __ ] choke somebody out too
yeah you know I love it actually Theo
the most
is look I'm an addict I'm a everything's
in addition to me like fishing I make
fishing in an addiction yeah I don't
know what one of anything is but part of
being an addict is I like to give with
conditions so if I send you like a
thank-you note I think I might have told
you this before a couple weeks go by I'm
like why didn't your anything from Theo
about the thank you know that I start
building a little resentment like what
deal we can't even thank me for send
them a nice note that's not what you
sent somebody something right so when
wrestling in the wrestling room coaching
it's the only time I'm selfless because
they can't give me anything back they
can't give me anything back except
feeling good about themselves yeah wow
the only I found a room two hours a day
grime selfless and I get nothing from it
except a kid going wow like I am better
than I thought and it makes me cry like
it me I Drive home sometimes I'm with
tears in my eyes that's cool man good
for you dude good for you good for you
I'll get you there I'm just say you're
my Sonia yeah it's a tall trouble
disabled I got like three kids in there
with mustaches it's a charter school I
got Mexicans I got kids coming from
South Central
I got Johnny Z got a mustache Cesar I
got a mustache little Anthony's got a
mustache a little Anthony always has a
Mustang little infinity any city you go
to a little honey has a mustache he
[ __ ] snuck into his [ __ ] stepdads
roof and cut part of his beard off he
used honey - [ __ ] him put it up above
his lip little Anthony's brand-new he's
like 105 pounds he's a freshman he talks
like Luis Guzman he's like listen why do
I got wrestling shows popping listen
what he did five it was like where do I
get wrestling shows like cuz I'm
wrestling a Sox as other ladies and is
there any guys do they have any
finishing moves or they dance after
anything like that has he gotten to that
point yet with wrestling no it's really
just it's - you know you can't like
dance and [ __ ] like that it's just still
mono e mono underwater when you're done
you know you shake the other cats and
you shake the other coaches hand wow the
only kid comes over and shakes your hand
you can wave to the coach or whatever
some kids are bent out of shape about it
but that's awesome
which all's team name the Panthers or
what is it the Dolphins yeah Wow really
Palisades yes
school chant like everywhere we go
people know who we are so we tell them
every day it makes me laugh
we are the Dolphins Marty Marty dolphins
I'm like really we can't change that the
pally wrestling yeah wrestling pally
pally wrestling my team dolphins not
yeah a lot of dolphins and dolphin get
caught on e in a little net dolphins a
gay shark yeah
a shark is a straight you know it
dolphins just like hey blow dude if they
pull if a cop pulled a dolphin over dude
I bet it would have a bunch of [ __ ]
nuts inside of it once the man's nuts
you know wouldn't be shocked is what I'm
saying overall yeah man that's why you
know so uh so I'm so jealous in a way
I'm so uh well that's awesome that you
found that thing that that you have that
place to be selfless man two years ago I
just did it two years ago
dolphins are dangerous animals I could
rape and kill your baby yeah if I put my
baby in the [ __ ] ocean yeah dude one
of these nitwits out there with that you
know trying to get the you know that
saltwater baby
trying to part its hair with a [ __ ]
water wave these people are out of their
minds man
but that's Palisades dude no no this is
soft patch up there is there are some
tough cats up there no we're tough yeah
we brought yeah I like that
we brought we're brawlers okay we got a
room in brawlers yeah I want to come
cheer him on
I'll let you know I think we have one
home duel match this year yeah we
wrestled Birmingham high last year they
have a hundred kids it's in the valley
they got a hundred kids in the wrestling
room a hundred they have a B team before
junior varsity they have two different
varsity's a B team and then they have JV
a hundred kids in the wrestling room
that's more than the reason a football
team yeah and we lost my six point like
we brought it next year with freshmen
and sophomores it's great oh we play
them this year be great is it crazy to
see like when you're looking back at
these children and a lot of because a
lot of children go through puberty at
that time you know yeah all of them do
it's got to be Chris yeah all children
do yeah well some graduates in the
onesie we have we are kids from our
school I don't think never hit it really
oh no these guys never hit a couple
young fella one dude works at the
CVS now having air where I used to live
but he [ __ ] is still swinging for it
bro
never hit it I don't know what that's
called what's a coma you don't hit
puberty Nick that's her buddy her buddy
you know I ever swim with dolphins have
I probably I don't know I been in the
water on her I mean on purpose like you
go oh no is go to a dolphin encounter no
I did it once and I like it didn't go
well what happened I brought my mom to
the Bahamas oh do you don't bring your
mom to a dolphin encounter great old
saying she she had a we knew she had
Alzheimer's so I just took her before
she was getting bad oh yeah tell her
it's Alaska huh yeah
climate change my I don't know yeah so
we go in the water and there's like this
11 minute video they show you a safety
video but it's [ __ ] dolphin so I just
took a nap and then I'm in the water and
I'm like what could go wrong it's a
dolphin
I'll tell you so my mom they go Jeannie
Jeannie you get Dottie and like this
beautiful dolphin comes out like a
beaded curtain it's like price is right
like Dottie and my mom and this dolphin
are like oh my god you're so precious
look like then with the high school
together like oh my god and then like
you get chipper like the [ __ ] bullpen
doors at Yankee Stadium open and they
play Enter Sandman by Metallica and
there's a wall of water coming at me and
he's just like coming at me I'm like I'm
gonna get cut in half by a dolphins head
I'm like he's just
I was scared it's like coming right at
me hits the brakes Wow rolls on his back
and he's floating on his back huh across
me with a look on his face like you got
I'm all right man day so I'm like okay
cool but he's got only a little patch of
white he's great being a patch of white
like chest air mhm I'm just kind of like
they go you can touch him um I'm rubbing
his chest what's his body like soft or
what is it it's real soft that means
things like a kind of a real hard spongy
you know it's what you can't explain it
but it's exactly what you think would
feel like I don't know what that is
though like it would be hard hard hard
like a car it well yeah but there's some
give to it it's like soft gahard foam in
a water park in the tubes oh yeah yeah
yeah so I'm at his chest and he's like
scooching by
and what it said in the video that I
slept through it was never ever under
any circumstances touch any of the
dolphins below their belly buttons but
he's going this way and I'm telling his
chest a little lower in his chest look
so I don't even realize it I'm like
jerking off Adolfo it's like a massage
parlor I'm like right it's like a
Westwood Boulevard like yeah like
nothing came out but he just goes and he
like flips out and he starts hitting me
in the ribs with his head in my life
vest like dang damn like what's he doing
I know what he's doing it was it
powerful hitting or yes like it's like I
don't belong with this aquatic mammal
like I am a visitor
and stuff like bang I know what he's
doing now I know what he was doing when
he's trying to get me in the middle of
the lagoon where nobody could help me oh
wow
then he goes underwater disappears my
mom and daddy are playing like [ __ ]
mahjong yeah and I'm like what's with
this guy where's chipper like treat me
like a tourist and then I feel like him
in my back and I shouldn't know what a
Dolphins dick feels like uh-huh I
shouldn't know you shouldn't never seen
one I've been down some rabbit holes on
pornhub
yeah I've seen guys pregnant wives head
getting trained by brothers um I've seen
[ __ ] everything you could think of
never seen the Dolphins deck never seen
a followed National Geographic slide
show science oh I couldn't pick one out
of a dick lineup right now let me tell
you something yeah when it's against
your body you know really it's the
aggression mmm like he was aggressive
and there's a space between my life vest
and my back oh yes it was too big and
that's where he got his dick Oh
against my back between the life vest
how much dick is in a dolphin too much
yeah way too much like it's it's up my
back and his head's like here and I
don't know it was just it was a bit long
I could imagine a me of being that long
and I don't want to see it Nick really
long I'll put it up there and I don't
know how to yell like a really long dude
does it feel like a like a long finger
does it feel like a like a wiener does
it feel like Oh like he was like grab me
from behind but something was between us
like a mini it was it I it still freaks
you just I knew what were you wearing a
big dude there's nothing shadier than
somebody wearing a freaking big life
jacket that's too big well vacation
they're either too small you throw them
to the side look no life that's not
vacation fits you for their xxx and a
clone of me
things like if not all the life s is too
big I'm you know I'm looking to meet
somebody you know good to know hopefully
yeah that's crazy bro so I don't know
how to yell like hey hey you're dolphins
because the guys are like up on these
rocks like your dolphins dick it's stuck
between my life vest on my back because
I jerked them off and he thinks it's my
[ __ ] so I just floated there and I
start yelling dolphin god stop I swear
the guy turns to me and he goes dolphins
rock you know it buddy
like knows I'm saying dolphin [ __ ] table
[ __ ] and then I'm completely alone and
they give you an 8 by 10 photo for free
like my mom as bad as her Alzheimer's
God she'd be like who are you I'm like
I'm JJ I'm your son
who's the man in the kitchen that's John
that's your husband you go never show
you the picture of my friend Dottie do
it you can see me sort of with all the
whitewash but he's up over my head his
life vest over my head like a hockey
jersey in a fight God then it sounds
like that's a for a rape case a little
bit it was rape II know I was it was
straight up a dolphin tried to [ __ ] me
dude imagine what he's telling his
buddies right now he's like hey mom [ __ ]
that come baby and go it the other day
you think he's funny i from haha little
hole hands were here whatever that is
you know his jokes didn't keep me from
[ __ ] imagine if he hit my [ __ ] I
would have died oh we are the Dolphins
the rapey wave of dog man not going
through puberty is called Coleman
syndrome just to put there we go
Deron Coleman actually I think was the
boy's name a key part tailed actually
and he wasn't they named it after him
yeah man that's crazy not going through
puberty what does it say about it it's
just 1 in 10,000 men have it
it's Wow and one it's high right yeah
okay there Willie have 4,000 in our
tails so this guy was like a real
entrepreneur again how did he monetize
not going through puberty oh I don't
know dude I think he probably well you
know a lot of these men will go back to
school even after they've graduated to
me younger girls and alike you have a
lot of cases of that right playing
Little League World Series yep
oh I'd go back I'd be
side linebacker and just crush yeah you
could do it oh you could do I do paint
your skin brown and get back there go
back to high school and just wrestle
like 180 students and go to a small town
some of the people in high school 3040
years old because they're dumb just
because it'll of the laws are different
you know you have to get out of it you
have to graduate school the only way
stick around is if you don't get out
yeah we had a guy that's kind of mr.
Larry that was in our class and that
dude had to be his big trick was it was
an urban gentleman he could come in the
bathroom piss over you back into the end
of the urinal here uses that means he
had a boner Oh what do you have yeah I
have a book you have to have one to
shoot a piss over there he was a champ
brother this guy but he was at the
school for so long he was in I think
fifth or sixth grade for so long and
finally that it's like you're you know
you work here he got a job as a
janitorial how so how old was mr. Larry
that you know of in high school like
what was the oldest that you can recount
I'd go and this was middle school up he
go 18 was he special like was he slow no
he was fast no I mean his brain was like
Italy slow laid some folks call the
Kaiser blade no I think he just didn't
care that much or at all I think he's
still team seventh-grade but he was
timely he showed up for school every day
but he also didn't care once he got
there now most people will show will not
show up yeah but he was very you know he
was on time the [ __ ] did he get laid no
not really he had a uh he didn't have
like that great of hair and stuff I
don't know I also I never I didn't hang
out with the mouse out of school and I
wasn't [ __ ] you know I was 13 years
old so I don't even know he was an urban
gentleman from what I remember you know
and also you know the world was in a
different font back then there was as
many colors back then that's correct you
know more
it was just rosy bit man I'm going to uh
I want to get my dates in here before I
forget yeah
he just sold out in Tempe this week and
I saw that it was sauce it I've been
here in so long I loved it so much I'm
doing Addison improv this weekend I love
that place in Dallas I love that place
the dates written down over there
sweetie
yeah Nick's gotta mom okay here we go
hired people were like hey you're
my talent I've like a 48-hour calendar
in my head yeah listen anything past
that I have no idea people like you're
coming to my town in three weeks I'm
like I guess like I guess I'm in my
you're in the town I get a lot of dates
man you got Tempe improv October 8th no
that's done
oh that's done Addison improv 25 26 27
Houston improv November 1st 3rd and then
Tampa Florida side splitters November
7th through 9th so and great all embraer
right after uh after Thanksgiving come
see me do comedy let's do it let's fill
it up
Charlotte Hollywood Delaware Atlantic
City Annapolis coming up in this is Phil
Texas let's get taxes fall off in the
spring yeah come on to ads let's see
who's gonna rally most that's a place
where Houston what Addison yeah I love
it too Trey's ago dude I love it man
that place is fun dude how much trouble
you gotten down in Tampa wonder okay
yeah you know I'm like I mean compared
to Tempe oh yeah like I got done with I
didn't ring my phone to the show so I
couldn't like be searching for [ __ ]
good and ER the things you're doing
these days to stay all like to try and
curb that kind of appetite that's one
thing it's it's a problem yeah it's a
problem it's just validation I need
validation and it's like whether it's
escorts
which is I prefer it yeah because I know
organized yeah it's like they're coming
over we're gonna do a thing and it's
gonna take place in this amount of time
and everybody yeah go on about their
business it's like going to some club
and some girl goes he raped me
yeah no you don't I got the recital go
to you know go to clubs yeah like I work
at a club right go home
so I leave right away I don't bring my
phone to the show and then I just like
read a book and try to fall asleep
there's nothing good out there you're
just gonna get in trouble what is that
thing inside of us cuz it look man I can
relate on over senator held my first car
was a Ford Escort so I should have known
right-handed but where did you go wrong
huh
oh yeah well we're nothing and drive
that [ __ ] run did I ever one time I was
driving naked around town right because
this is Backlund people didn't know if
you were naked you know and the cop
there was a [ __ ] pit bulls yeah
alright this is back when people didn't
know whether or not you were naked yeah
now everybody tells everybody they're
like oh you know they'll make a funny
video or something back in the day you
can drive with no pants on yeah or no
shirt nothing and you're like oh he's
got a shirt off it's odd out yeah now
you'd be like the guys [ __ ] naked a
yes alright nice but now it's like you
can do this back then you would just
cruise around naked pull up talk to
people in the yard and [ __ ] the [ __ ]
why because it was fun Jay you know
disagree it was women was running fear
of getting caught
no I don't keep down the story cuz
you're too good a storyteller for me to
be you know that's back when it was the
Wild West dude you know you could just
hey how are you guys do you guys just
move in here - some lady if I can you
know cutting her kids hair and your
heart and you're just sitting there
[ __ ] butt-naked but would she ever
see that you were naked or oh they
thought you were dissipate just a local
neighbor nice you're a citizen you were
a citizen
yeah you're a local citizen didn't make
a neck of one yeah you were one of the
you were one of the many citizens that
did that hit puberty locally and you
were [ __ ] living enough to his
driving around town you know I'd love to
drive around naked might when I had my
Escalade I would drive back to Orange
County every day after I was working and
I just I'm like why can't I just see
somebody playing with her [ __ ] of my
own never saw it you know I wasn't
looking down into buddy's car excited
truck oh yeah that's nice when with the
San Francisco when I was crossing the
Bay Bridge I'm like everyone smoking
reefer like everyone in the car like it
was alive was the only one not smoking
grass in my car
I couldn't believe different times man
you sick honey buddy
yeah copter I caught a cold the other
day that's terrible it's the worst man
but yeah man I've been doing pretty good
with the partner I've been doing real
good with the pornography I got back
onto it a couple months ago are you
still watching it no I'm about two weeks
clean right now I think three weeks I've
never made the efforts and I watch it at
all really at all do you got to get the
apps man what's that
what else there's an app called mobisit
that's for your phone and there's a
different that's I'm a computer let me
know what it is anymore
oh covenant eyes you once I got the hats
one of the rabbit what do they have to
do they you cannot look up any
pornography you know just use your
imagination you can't even look up like
woman's hat if you want to buy your mom
a hat or something or if it's you know
like a Kentucky Derby or something you
can't even get that you can't even get
it I've been talking about I need like
some kind of block oh it's a boat and
once I did that here's the funny thing I
found out about an airplane looking at
porn on my phone oh that's disgusting
I dressed guys draw a picture okay
driving around town naked yeah but
you're young you know at that point you
can get out of [ __ ] sheltered jaemor
gets mustard looking at this point
yeah mobisit and we don't work for them
I wish we did man I wish I worked with
them I would like someone if someone
knows of a pornography app they want to
build one and we want to work together
to offer a cheaper alternative to people
this one is it's expensive it's $15 a
month now the value is immense though
because here's what I realized I'm too
lazy then like my my addiction my
addiction to look at sexual deviance
online it falls off once it's in and
once it's not easily accessible I give
up my dick I don't have that addiction
that's like oh you know that younger I'm
gonna get through his firewall I'm gonna
fix it yeah or like I'm gonna drive
around naked like I you know had when I
was young what about dating apps nope I
took them all off my phone yeah the time
suck women just want to be pen pals on
those things oh yeah it's a lot of I
think I think it's a lot of lonely women
just wanting to be yeah I got kicked off
a dating app they thought I was
catfishing ladies as jaemor I got an
email everything I don't it was rhymes
with OkCupid I'm like do I fight these
people and go like no I am Jay Mohr let
me go see a whole bunch of sixes and
fives I'm like whatever man and then
you're like ladies are [ __ ] up the
dating app game like full body shots
only I went on a date the girl was
beautiful in her photo like full body
shots only because you fat [ __ ] you
tricked me one time she shows up to the
date through the wall like [ __ ] cool
a big flat saw with a pretty face oh
yeah
I'm there for [ __ ] yet with rice
she's much like Jesus Christ grimace
like what she was gorgeous yeah yeah she
was it's a lot of trickery bruh right
and filters on the photo they show up
you're like you're not a panda but can
you imagine this though all the tricky
then having to show up somewhere
they got balls on them big fat [ __ ]
comes in like Jeeves a [ __ ] fatso
that's crazy
you know you're fatso mention it by the
way I don't know if you know who is yeah
I've always seen my face I'm a big fat
[ __ ] yeah I'm a lord
yeah I like to stay large man or I don't
know you know this gives you barley on
the app you know you only seen my face
but yeah I want you to be surprised or
shocked or set back or put off because
when you see all of me now I'm a big fat
[ __ ] you know I missed it I could put my
hands in my pockets when I'm naked I'm a
big gal have a big gal you know I'm
shaved I don't know what's been going on
I've been on these dating apps you know
how about that that Bumble yeah that's
good because that one Scrolls up and
down not left and right yeah so if
you're an information on lady I have to
go down to the bottom you know and then
weigh the Vitamix says she lives in st.
Louis all right well I do yeah st. Louis
Cardinals fan
what the H yeah what am i hugging gonna
take her out for a Bush bear I can go
down a rabbit hole sometimes I just
can't stop doing it a norm some people
are saying you're still living with your
mother is that your that's crazy talk
yeah yeah I'm a drive around a Kunis
Louisiana naked just cuz I like that gal
that cuts her kids hair on the lawn you
know yeah yeah neighborly yeah Toby's my
yeah yeah I like these girls on the apps
that go long-term relationship only yeah
I don't believe that's true
nobody feel walks out into a car
unless they want to buy her [ __ ] have
you been with some pretty bigger girls
norm you seem like a guy that knows his
way around a uh you know a real uh a
2-bedroom lady you know yeah that's
funny
clean up to bed oh I don't think I'm
making fun oh dude
everybody's making hundred or more he's
the best no he's the best
well I'm Nolan I am NOT Joel I don't
think you make up no I know you um what
was the thing here's hell no on the
dating app I do do a joke on stage it's
like long-term relationship only like
really yeah like sure like that's my
joke like nobody goes on the car lot
unless they wanted my Akaka a long-term
relationship only dad how'd you meet mom
I swiped right while I was taking a [ __ ]
I know huh I'm saying long-term
relationship only it's [ __ ] tinder
socket yeah do you think let's get this
question a question came in from a young
male actually and it's a norm account
related this is your friend Ryan from
Antioch California right now I'm
supposed to be delivering pizzas but the
pressing thing of my life is asking you
guys a question
mostly Jay but hey it's okay so my
question is is what is your favorite
Norm Macdonald story I have a feeling I
know what you're gonna say but who cares
tell the story anyways we all love it
it's the best story ever I don't know
what story's talking about but he thinks
he knows I'm gonna tell us my favorite
nor McDonald's story I don't know either
I was that a California Pizza man oh
yeah yeah bunch of wheels yeah big fat
wife big fat [ __ ] you know of giving an
ear written beautiful big guy Wow you
know I'll take care of everything I'm
gonna order pizza yeah I don't make
everybody happy
yeah that guy is asking questions on the
Obon podcast his pipe seven minutes late
Wow that [ __ ] guy's wife digestive
you can I go insane it's so good though
my favorite thank you my favorite nor
McDonald's stories probably when you
guys don't know
within my book is when he would oh I
okay greatest I know I think I know what
he's talking about
Wow what was the kid's name oh yeah a
pizza man
anthe Ryan louder back Ryan louder from
the Antioch louder back you know not to
be confused with the ones in Pahrump huh
I don't know what's going on we were
writing a sketch well I was watching
other people write and rewrite a sketch
and there's like 30 writers and the
sketch was David Spade Fred wolf wrote
it for David Spade original and it was a
weight-loss supplement but it was just
PCP and crack oh yeah put in a milkshake
and you smoke it and you just go about
your day and then like you know when
they show like a fat person becoming a
skinny person that says like you know 16
weeks like six hours yeah
and David's like I'm gonna help you lose
weight you're like ride the snake you
got to ride the snake
don't let snake ride you and then they
just have all these people like
shrinking into like skeletal bodies and
because they're just it's just growl
drugs yeah that's drug laid back
they say drug-related and they have
Farley a pre-filmed piece of Farley in a
drive-thru window that they're gonna cut
to in the in the in the sketch and
Farley pulls up to a drive-thru window
and he goes I'll have he's one of the
people that are just started oh yes I'll
have 14 cheeseburgers 14 hamburgers four
vanilla milkshakes six strawberry
milkshakes three chocolate milkshakes
six apple pies and it just goes on and
on and on and the rewrite it was like
from 1:00 in the morning till 3:00 in
the morning I'm not kidding it was two
hours guys from Harvard Brown Yale
arguing over what Oh cuz the guy goes
will there be anything else and what he
says next for two hours they're like how
many repeats the exact same order again
yeah how about he says all that and goes
a diet coke company says all that and
goes make that nine apple pie when I say
two hours - I'm not kidding
from 1 a.m. to 3 a.m. and what we didn't
know was norm was sitting on a couch at
the other end of the writers room and
it's just going around and it's crass I
could totally imagine that too but it's
like they're just huge order anything
else and he goes yeah because he was
like yeah anything else yes and then
what comes after he says yes that's the
whole crux of the origin and norm goes
we know visa trivial yeah you guys we're
all jumpy hey you guys got Chris go and
give me all that food like 14 of those
things and 25 apple pies you know and
the guy and the box goes uh hey well
will that be all
why is the Chris go yes it's the
greatest rewrite in the history of
comedy no I also want an enormous thing
was like he had pride like you had
control after all the [ __ ] food he
goes yes one syllable one syllable we
were on the ground rolling laughing and
then when they filmed it he's like all
day 14 cheeseburgers um 44 fries and
this and 22 cheese milkshakes and this
and the app behind the guys will that be
all it probably goes yes
he's proud of himself it was [ __ ]
amazing it was why not um one thing
that's funny uh-oh here he said ask you
to write dirty work to so I worked all
day yesterday I'm finished it this is
normally Donald Twitter just yesterday
uh he's working on dirty work too well
it's gotta be a parody tweet cuz it's a
500 page manuscript scriptures about 106
pages what I think he's actually got
some pages out wait wait what did he
cross half we wrote North written by me
Oh dirty work - no I'm done pranking now
I'm married to a beautiful scientist Oh
Brad Pitt's in it
rich and she has a beautiful face and we
have a cat named kitty and we love kitty
like a child you guys well Marge cannot
have children because the chemicals in
her lab have rendered her barren
rendered her barren why go home and read
that do you think one of the reasons
that um what did norm do after SNL did
he just tour he had a sports show on
Comedy Central I've briefly people loved
him it was so much I'm one of those
people I'm powerless he makes me laugh
so hard yeah did he just make me laugh
through you so hard that yes was
probably the most I've laughed in months
man that's that's in my book there
gasping for air time book it was like
[ __ ] it was a one syllable yeah that
was yes look we'd argue over what to
name of high school like opening opening
shot of Jefferson High to urban [ __ ]
high school high don't be too jokey yeah
don't tip it this like all these things
you don't even know what it means in
high school David Spade the other day
was yeah she's funny guy man he was
telling me an or McDonald's story where
they all went on a plane to do a show
somewhere together and he just said one
of the ways that Norman makes you laugh
he'll be like what is this and it's just
a like a door you know any like or like
a cherry like David what is a you sit
down it it's not the age yeah what is
this little ledge here you he's like
it's a chair norm its chair then what
are you doing with it there's there's
three of them right here it's just I'm
not singing that but he and he went on
like this five-minute monologue of Noir
McDonald asking him what a bathroom door
was and it was one of the funniest
things that I ever heard it was just
yeah he just says I don't know if it's
his voice or what it is about nor
McDonald that just makes I mean I don't
know it just did there's nobody likely a
thing making that sound right it's a dog
whistle it's the it's the only you can
only get nor McDonald with no McDonald
it's the only sentient being that emits
that transmission okay
yeah like we all got like all these
influences going through us at different
times and regional accents and dialects
he's just norm yeah and now if I got
like no one walked into a place to get
work and be like ah nah man yeah it's
just so they've missed a lot of norms I
feel like I thought there's been a lot
of norms over the years they might have
missed I know you want more of je more
pretty bad joke there but I got to pay
the bills man and and let's talk about
one of my favorite things honestly the
holidays and people think the holidays
what is it you know people think holla
holla
and people just yelling at each other
that's not it it's a seasonal time it's
at the end of the year and I know it's
crazy to talk about him this early but
uh but you don't want to go through
another holiday season taking
closed-mouth photos while everyone else
is grinning ear-to-ear so get a photo
ready smile and you got to do that in
advance and advance is now it's easier
than ever with clear aligners from
candid candids aligners can help
straighten your teeth faster than
traditional wire braces or brasses
treatment takes just six months on
average so think about your smile right
now and think about how great it can be
down the road think about how great it
can be in your holiday photos candid
ships your aligners directly to you so
there's no hassle go into a dentist's
office and candidate cost 65% less than
actual braces or bra size get your foot
already smile by the holidays go to
candid co.com / Theo and use code Theo
to get $75 off that's candid CA ND ID co
dot c om / th EO code Theo for $75 off
if you're going to look at these
different companies that uh that have
the ability to make your smile different
check out candid and check out our offer
through them seventy five dollars off
candy
co.com /t heo code Theo
now look I can also tell you something
special if Li know just want a million
dollars betting on football
so Jesus man and all this time I've been
praying and doing these scratchers so
let me just got to take a bigger chance
and and for me now that's gonna be my
bookie you know I might you know I got
LSU coming up against Alabama in here a
few weeks and I know I'm a lay a little
bit of wager
I got money tonight on the Jay ETS Jets
Jets Jets plus nine and a half against
New England's if you're the kind of guy
who likes you bet a little and win a lot
try a parlay if you like a couple of the
big favorites add them up stack them you
know maybe you take a New Hampshire
maybe you takin a Tallahassee add them
up same card six dollars get that big
hitter but if you're gonna bet this
season do the smart thing and go to my
bookie dot AG because no one gives you
more ways to win that's the thing they
do a lot of these gambling sites they
don't let you do the parlays they don't
let you do the magic touches but they do
it at my bookie dot a g.com and if you
join right now my bookie
will double your first deposit that's
right if you want to lay seven hundred
and air two hundred or 80 they're gonna
double that use promo code Theo to
activate the offer that's promo code th
EO to double your cash visit my bookie
AG today you play you win you get paid
Artie Lange told me they were doing San
Francisco together and Artie it was open
from there in San Francisco and uh rape
floor he goes on stage no I'm gonna hey
Artie no no I don't do any of that [ __ ]
stuff yeah don't don't do any don't do
any of that [ __ ] stuff out there San
Francisco you can't go out there and do
homosexual jokes you know
I like to yeah you can't you can't do
any of that gay [ __ ] stuff you get it's
not gonna fly here you know you have to
have respect for where you are yeah so
he goes out this 20 minutes mother comes
out his first joke yeah how many [ __ ]
you have AIDS
they say it's does not discriminate but
only gay guys have right that's kind of
discriminatory no and I think not
discriminating supposed to be a good say
something like that but she goes right
on stage yeah how many [ __ ] here have
eight hey don't do it against Oh God
here man what a puppeteer a lot of them
yeah I'd love to be in his head for a
minute any reminds me of like a Midwest
and of like a you know of like just uh
he reminds me of like so many characters
that you just don't see anymore you know
yeah I mean you and you never have seen
a guy like that like it's always been
off the beaten path yes like guys like
norm guys like Colin Quinn guys like
like Richard Lew think of how much they
had to bomb before they found a theater
of people that came to see them
regularly that mastered that because
it's such a finite frequency like Dennis
Miller I learned a lot like Dennis
Miller's off-white album and the HBO
special that it was was called mr.
Miller goes to Washington i I've
listened to that more and send more from
my comedy in my life than all comedy
albums combined because he's making
those crazy references and like you know
two-thirds of the audience don't even
know what it means but the rhythm still
great but the people that do get it
they're never not gonna see him right
it's like oh my god he said Twyla Tharp
it's just it's insane so like Colin
Quinn stuff and like norm stuff like
when Richard Lewis got going emo Philips
yeah like these guys were so like what
what's happening like Dennis wolfburg
like way back guys like
like when Kinnison started was like
what's happening it wasn't what
everybody else was doing yeah it's like
listening to poison and Cinderella and
then James addiction comes along you're
like woo God
wow it's different it's great it's new
right so then like the fact that they go
out that like they just they were game
they kept going you know it's so true
when you when I like a lot of times
people will submit me like if you will
submit music to because they want to be
they want to be on the front of the
podcast right cousins we put new music
on their music from different listeners
and stuff and and it's awesome and I'm
grateful for the submissions but some of
you're like oh this band sounds just
like right this other band and then I
started to think like yeah the real way
to be novel is not to be like okay this
is what's going on I'm gonna do that
right and succeed with that it's to find
whatever voice inside of you is
different and it's gonna be [ __ ]
Rocky for a while because nobody's gonna
believe that that's the next sound that
that's the thing until you get it
fine-tuned you know I think you're I
think you're right but I think you're
alongside it and that is not fine the
voice that nobody else is doing you just
have to find your [ __ ] voice right
and then maybe it's one that nobody else
is doing right like Jane's Addiction as
an example we were all it was like
poison Cinderella Motley Crue girls
girls girls
and then Jane's Addiction was like all
it was all treble and his voice was real
tinny and weird and Dale Morrow had
these like landscape he sounds like this
is [ __ ] evil what's happening and
like there's very few band
yeah that's he's gotta be true to
yourself like in comedy like they go if
I do interviews and they're like so
what's your what's your point of view
like what like from here's my point of
view yeah like what does I think that me
I've been answered a dozen times what's
my point of view yeah I don't [ __ ]
know dude were you coming from one stage
where you come from yeah what do you
talk about yeah yeah people say what do
you talk about [ __ ] stuff yeah it's
like the biggest I mean imagine asking
like a painter so like what do you paint
before he paints yeah cuz we
on stage yet it's different every night
yeah and that's why it comedy is the
greatest art form it's the most art art
form the risk yeah it's not forget about
that sometimes not poetry not any art
form you can think of comedy blows it
out of the water and I can prove the the
size every single viewing the materials
change the size of the frame changes the
way people are looking at it one night
it's a sculpture one night it's like
looks like a [ __ ] Jackson Pollock the
length of time it is is different all
the time the people looking at it make
it different every time
it's it's crazy it's like a guy making a
making like a yeah it's like making
ravioli and a and a matrix and so that's
neat way to put it yeah it's like you're
just working with like we control time
yeah we literally Bend time you tell a
story about when you were a kid I was
watching the cartoon about Halloween in
the back your mom's oh yeah you know
pick up and so yeah the station wagon
but if I'm listening that without the
car is so funny buddy I saw thanks man
yeah it's so good somebody's doing that
with you it's fallen but when you tell
that story without that without the
cartoon for me to stare it I'm there I'm
I'm I'm picturing the car and the heat
in the car you driving around naked and
the lady color kids hair on their front
lawn oh yeah things like that I'm there
I pictured a yard in my head yeah I
pictured what the roads look like there
probably weren't sidewalks yeah yeah
you're probably in like a Ford Granada
or some or you said what kind of car
like 40 I actually created a town in my
head no other art does that the other
art goes this is what you're looking at
this is blue that's orange and it's all
like mushy mush and it kind of looks
like a guy's falling down or this is a
sculpture that's what you're looking at
we say [ __ ] in the audience creates what
it is in your head yeah like George
Carlin goes the best to me the best
comedy in Scent best sentence in comedy
[ __ ] Tucker Tucker sucks he's talking
about soft names make soft people I'm
getting sick of guys named Todd and Cody
and Dylan and Tucker yeah [ __ ] Tucker
Tucker
sucks there is no Tucker you have to
create your own Tucker in your head as
an audience member yeah cya him to the
point of applause in this amount of time
now like [ __ ] Tucker tuck [ __ ] Tucker
Tucker so there's only three words in
that sentence yeah cuz Tucker's repeated
[ __ ] Tucker Tucker stuck in that amount
of time you have to create a Tucker and
I [ __ ] hate the guy I just thought of
yeah it's in say he's a wizard and I'm
and [ __ ] Todd and guys that look like
Todd and you're like yeah you don't even
know hearing no you only fire a [ __ ]
you'll marry a human being in your head
oh there's Mike put an arrow and gas and
light and [ __ ] fire it into a damn
field at odds brushing spirit who what
t-shirts hit the baseline um are you
star you watching uh are you watching
any sport to you what still watching
hoops yeah well it seasons about the
star what do you think of this Chinese
fallout it's a tough awesome man
it's about them look let's not let's not
[ __ ] it let's call a spade a spade yeah
half the almighty dollar
yeah NBA's got billions of dollars
rolling in
they knew that going in risky and that's
how they're not the first company no to
make inroads in China and go like II
don't do that we're making millions and
billions of dollars yeah this what and
this was LeBron right here talking about
it and LeBron is such a sorry going Nick
all talk about this
yes we all do have freedom of speech but
at times there are ramifications for the
negative that can happen when you're not
thinking about others you know only
think about yourself so I don't believe
I'm gonna get into a word or sentence
feud with Darrell with Darrell more but
I believe he wasn't educated on the
situation at hand
and any spoke and
so many people could have been harmed
not only financially but physically
emotionally spiritually so just be
careful what we we tweet and we say what
we do even though yes we do have freedom
speech but there can be a lot of
negative iced tea freedom of speech just
watch what you say it's hard what you
boy doesn't like daryl morey that's for
sure well what you become part of
because in fact it is his bottom line
he's alright it'll be fun like if
somebody if like Rob palinka tweeted
that he wouldn't have that take if a
Lakers guy tweeted that right he
wouldn't throw him under the [ __ ] bus
it's family but it's a guy from the
Rockets oh that's a good point
oh yeah like if you're not educated on
the issues like what education do I need
the fact that they're fighting for
democracy right you know but he's right
though they could have been physically
like I know people in the Lakers
organization that were concerned they
that like they wanted him home like
let's are they gonna come home right are
they going to come home yeah one of my
friends works for the NBA he was over
there and he said the second that it all
kind of went down that after that they
always felt watched after that court you
know when Nixon went to China and the
motorcade from the airport to whatever
like the ambassador's palace everybody
on the street was an actor playing a
person on the street Wow
not amazing didn't want anybody getting
out of line they hired actors to be the
guy with the newspaper walking to his
car they had a lady with a baby that was
an actress like just people just Nixon
looking out the window and find people
here yeah there were all actors from
that whole route that he followed us
praying they're doing the roles okay
dude China doesn't play man I went to
China last year to China dude yeah what
to Shanghai or something oh yeah
Shanghai and some comedy there other
areas yeah did comedy over there for a
lot of expats a lot of that's amazing
see oh yeah it was pretty cool man it
was um might have been a year and a half
ago Wow but China doesn't play do China
but there was no white people there's
nobody it's just Chinese people
you can't go stay in China you can't
show up in China with no papers a mill
around China doesn't give a [ __ ] dude
I've said it before you walking down the
street in China you die they make a soup
out of you buddy
you know
and they do it gracefully brah now there
there's love and there's a lot of like
you know like but they're moving forward
you know I'm saying they're like we're
using you as nutrients we're gonna go
build you know do whatever we need to do
and stop moving your internal some
windows or [ __ ] dude you got people
[ __ ] blow and drywall with their own
mouths bro you don't you got people
[ __ ] dude you'll have one guy mixing
asbestos in another guy's open mouth bro
they're not playing yourself at a hair
dude I think the easiest job in the
world cuz comedies maybe one of the
hardest ones right police sketch artist
EJ that's got to be an easy job you know
yeah I'll tell you the easiest job in
the world police sketch artist in China
guy comes they go I got Chinese police
hell yeah I just got robbed and they go
hey we got it five five straight black
hair Marlboro Reds yeah we got his photo
you know oh my god that's awesome man
it's me dude it's all you know it's a
that's Colin I think like the easiest
job in the world is probably police
sketch artist in China yeah some guy
comes in with a straight a Chinese
policeman I just got robbed like yeah we
mean who he is
we're on the lookout five five straight
black hair Marlboro Reds smushed in nose
okay
we don't even Italian with Down syndrome
maybe all right yeah
or that can also be a Jim Norton if he
has to run to the airport in like an
hour he catches flight because it's a
little more antsy when he has to go
either way both of our [ __ ]
immaculate oh my goodness what does arts
it's like a strong area it's you know we
was in here over an hour you know well
what is this this big chunk of wood here
look this used to be a tree or something
there's a table norm is a table oh what
a table like um you know if you want to
set things on stuff or you don't want to
hold on to stuff all the time
I may be an old chunk of coal here yeah
and I may have been born at night but I
wasn't born last night but if I want to
set things go like emotional baggage for
past relationships our regret I don't
see how this well what is it called a
table it's for a table yeah like if you
want to do a puzzle Wow understand what
is this wood yeah this why still yes
this time what kind of wood is your
tailor I think maple now did you have to
make a table out of a certain kind of
wood or if I could lose the umbrellas
good I'm struggling here
I loved it man [ __ ] his clothes never
got to know him I've asked him 40 times
come on yourself well you know 47th time
is the charm is what no one ever says
you know um do you think what these
athletes getting back to the best of all
do you think what these athletes that
LeBron is like a business though it's
not even like a person on the court
anymore at a certain point it's just
you're too big you can't do he can't say
anything he wants to he's not making his
own usually does he usually does yeah
he's usually very outspoken because the
the Commissioner wanted the players to
be available for the media in China
mm-hmm but the Commissioner in the NBA
hadn't had an official statement yet so
LeBron was the guy that led the players
to say whoa
work you haven't spoken to the media we
didn't do anything wrong right you
addressed it we're not gonna go talk to
get fed to the Wolves so like that's
LeBrons power hmm is there like okay
it's media day in LeBrons like no it's
not we're not doing media because you
have not spoken to the media you're the
commissioner you're in charge
wow that's that's gravitas man yeah
that's gravity just today the Chinese
state broadcaster said Commissioner Adam
Silver will face retribution sooner or
later for saying that Beijing wanted him
to fire daryl morey so like like that
you can't win with these folks is this
camera right here yes China suck my dick
I'll say it in Chinese suck my dick yeah
like [ __ ] relax China [ __ ] stop
China won't stop dude I'm telling you
bro their game give us
yeah their game this but their gaming
when you when the dog goes in the cage
they [ __ ] decorate you know mean you
go to China will [ __ ] clean house
Chinese women bro dude do you can't vote
there's not even you're not cleaning
house over there man joke oh yeah like
there's gonna be red I think that
retribution to the NBA commissioner like
they're gonna [ __ ] slap his neck when
he's sleeping you know what they'll do
they'll probably get three guys on each
other's shoulders put him in a like a
warm-up outfit get him onto a team and
just have him doing wild layups and then
I think we all know how the Chinese are
gonna but tribution and I'm sober and
that is of course three words how
unfastening one fan raised 43 one Laker
fan raised forty three thousand dollars
to hand out stand with Hong Kong
t-shirts at the Lakers season opener
because Hong Kong the season opener
that's coming up a lot in China no no no
yeah baby in jail yeah yeah it's
interesting how it's like well I'm sorry
he raised money to make [ __ ] t-shirts
yeah it was that he doesn't mean Theo
your money your creeps [ __ ] t-shirt
man yeah people gave him how much
forty-three thousand to make t-shirts
damn I'll just read each yeah cause two
bucks to make [ __ ] rules you got taken
how many people can even fit in the
state in yeah it's an it sixteen
thousand twenty twenty-two something so
yeah they got taken but it's just why I
think everybody understand should be
like this every time there's a free
throw airway just going like every time
is afraid that you see the audience are
waving like no sniper sticks what did
you see like some guy goes to the line
and is deeply I don't know like six
hundred people that like oh that's how
you [ __ ] with China the protesters might
take offense to that - that's the crazy
thing dude it's not a democracy or not
right right to do it people are like
it's their right to throw me out of
Staples Center - I'm not [ __ ] doing
and I'm a company man
dude it's I'm not [ __ ] on my Lakers
relationship but you'll have so many
people in America it's like oh we got a
you know everybody we have to be so
welcoming to other countries we have to
be so welcome any child lives we
to make America more like China so
people from China can fit in but if you
made America more like China then you'd
be making it a [ __ ] it is more like
China we have a [ __ ] dictator but I'm
just saying you'd be making it um if you
made it more like I don't know what I'm
[ __ ] saying bro [ __ ] I hate talking
sometimes a man not as not as much as I
hate talking really I can't stop I just
found out I was bipolar three weeks ago
did you really diagnose the forty nine
years old am i you think no [ __ ] bipolar
type - I need something you don't you
know I swear
let's just keep talking off air but
you're all right yeah it's this town
[ __ ] what you do
yeah this town don't [ __ ] with you dude
who's this guy Martin Harris that the
lead singer of a razor lips like sugar
see a big fan of the podcast appreciate
your work Jay big fan of your career in
general one of my favorites of all time
it's one that flies under the radar I
feel and that's mafia hilarious movie
it's been a favorite of mine for years I
would love to know a little bit more
about how that came to be made and if
you have any good stories surrounding
that flick it's an absolute riot to
watch I also really enjoyed the doc that
you made about HR from Bad Brains how
did that come about super interesting I
didn't know that your background was in
you know hardcore punk stuff like that
do you have any other favorite bands
from the genre from the era whether it's
New York DC gang brah that's gang guy
that you yeah and we pull up I go to
youtube finding Joseph and so mafia is
one of my favorite movies I ever did for
many different reasons
a I never was in a comedy before that
was my first comedy being a comedian why
I done 14 movies and other my first
comedy but it wasn't really a comedy for
me because it took the guys did the
airplane and hot shot so everything I
said is the movie venture knows that him
know Jim Abraham's so everything I said
I had to say straight and all the
craziness happens around yeah you're
just a son likes QT stewardess I speak
chive like she's not making it she's not
acting like a joke
like an airplane she has to say it
straight like she speaks jive so it was
so much
I made good dough and it's the only
movie I ever auditioned for that they
told me I had it at the audition Wow I
auditioned they go so you want it this
is great you want to do it I'm like yeah
how much you want to be paid
I go six hundred thousand dollars they
go great I'm like [ __ ] I should have
said 1 million yeah yeah yeah 3 minutes
I gotta go to practice understood this
is the this is available everywhere does
the documentary made with James lay
those the director he handed me a whole
bunch of footage of the band Bad Brains
and we sort of redirected it towards
mental health do you know the band Bad
Brains do you're about to get educated I
want and this was a I'm I'm as proud of
this of anything I've ever done this
about three years ago we finally got it
sold so he'll dig it
greetings in the name of his Imperial
Majesty Jer Rastafari and this is a
documentary you produce director
executive Wow it looks good man it's
fantastic my friend Scott I love that
dude he loves all kind of music Bad
Brains the lead singer he's the lead
singer of Bad Brains it's there one of
the most important punk bands ever
that's like 1980 from DC a bunch of
black guys doing punk bunch of Roscoe's
to put the from DC they're all like
military gets to to him were how did you
get on to him
I'm punk rock I like punk you like Henry
what's his name Henry Wallace he's like
when he's he like boughs at the altar of
Bad Brains so really I know if he boughs
to anybody he's gonna do it everybody
yeah he loves like he was in that scene
and then Fugazi came out of DC yeah yeah
these they start at all like he Kenny
puppy was that one or not
I'm looking from DC but I acid bath or
no Beastie Boys sample Bad Brains like
round that's like a break from a bad
brain song and
Jane's Addiction Perry Farrell was asked
out what their music sounds like and he
goes we're across between Duke Ellington
and bad break his old guy goes what's a
bad ring like some old documentary so
you're one of the neatest Bad Brains I
know man I got good brains bad brains
they're just brains my brains
well what do you mean
hey I notice you have a thing on your
head is your head okay because you have
bananas where your hair should be well
what happened maybe there's a banana
accident it's like yeah yeah maybe maybe
you're a monkey's uncle
I think that's perfect man one of the
baddest brains I know J Moore thanks for
coming in today man I love all of you
too man
yeah that's life sentence straight up
you and 24/7 wake me up you need
something I got it yeah man they say in
Hawaii this guy once said to me I was
breaking his balls we're shooting
something in the ad was Hawaiian and
Korean Tommy Tommy Cho all right we
doing it are we doing it are we doing it
or what's happening if the lights go
well I was being a dick and he goes hey
if Ken can if no can know Ken so if Ken
can do you know what they say don't come
on my back and tell me it's raining
brother you feel me oh yeah let me know
you're coming on my back so I enjoy it
here's a white supremacist real quick
let's [ __ ] get this guy in more my
question is for you do the news in a gym
Bert Kreischer currently it's got a beef
at night in a gym Murray's you do this
guy seems like a rumor what are we doing
like acting performances for the
questions like I'm supposed to be
delivering pizzas but everybody Shatner
they all try to be feel a little bit do
you and they I don't think it's steel
like it's more maybe maybe that one
wasn't but like you and Bert Kreischer
happy rumor has it what you do know I
think they're doing this thing I got
[ __ ] kids I'm divorced twice I've
gotten sober twice I give him the IRS
$700,000 twice like a [ __ ] beef with
anybody rule by the way there's no room
yeah rumor doesn't it the first of all
rumor never hit that guy yeah I mean I'm
glad that guys support in the podcast
but also that guy has on no shirt and
beanie which older guy that guy's legit
are you cold or not
fight he's in his gym [ __ ] put in
work and in the middle of working out he
goes let me get this question where do
you get finding Joseph where can you get
it you got to look it up because the
director panicked and sold it to a
lesser distributor it should be on
iTunes and [ __ ] Netflix but the
director took the like a little more
money for it to be on a different
platform you can buy it on YouTube
that's one place but I was there anybody
I have no idea where but it's out there
out of some Texas you got to come back
again soon man
and into Monday's I know these I'm
always free I've kind of do you do this
every week a couple times a week yeah
once we be doing less gas but I talk to
you forever it's easy sometimes come
back next Monday you just shove it and
make it an evergreen show some people
it's uh we're just come back we'll do
we'll do next my dad loved to have you
back come on we're talking about
whatever if Ken can if Ken can can can
hey remember what the flash said when he
was walking over the mirror he'll that's
one way of looking at it you know uh-huh
now we're gonna addicted to doing norms
like quiet voice there's this guy yeah
and we were like yeah we are going
across Ontario and everything that is
bad guy you know that's like when you
really can get an impression I give you
do the person quiet I love that like
Christopher Walken all right man I gotta
go to practice and change some lives and
you change mine buddy game bro good game
I love you love you too man get back in
the ocean with me I will new paddle
boards really yeah he's like an aircraft
carrier oh yeah do that c-130 huh
[Music]
it's gonna take
little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]